I still remember that day.
We had won a game of hockey...
...and our coach had invited us home for a celebration dinner.
While everybody's eyes were on the fried fish, I couldn't take mine off Cynthia.
She was the coach's daughter and the most beautiful girl I had ever seen.
That night, I understood the meaning of love at first sight.
Cynthia was just 18, and I didn't know how to tell her that I love her.
So, I somehow gathered the courage and proposed to her with a song.
I turned 100 this year.
I couldn't have gotten this far without my Cynthia.
What can I say?
I was just lucky that I found her.
And so on this day, every year, I sing her that song...
...just to let her know that I still feel the same way I did...
...the first time I saw her.
One day, when we were young, this wonderful morning in May,...
...darling, you told me you loved me, one day when we were young.
Remember, you loved me, one day when we were young.